SPEAKER: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DUANE BONING: So
what I want to do
today is pick up a little
bit from last time,
round our discussion
of process optimization
with a little bit of a
different perspective today.
Last time we talked about
response surface methods
and using those in optimization.
What I want to do today
is especially focus on--
geez.
This arrow is not
letting me draw.
I want to focus on
process robustness,
and that's a little bit of
a different perspective.
So far, most of the
optimization we talked about
was looking at getting a
model of the mean response
and then using that to drive the
process to an optimum target,
if you will.
So we want to come back
a little bit to ideas
of things like CPK, quality
loss function, and so on,
that start to fold in
additional requirements
or additional goals
in the optimization.
Coming out of this
is little bit more
of an explicit consideration
of variation modeling,
not simply the mean
response, but also
thinking about this
assumption that we've
made that the variance
is the same everywhere
across the process
and what to do
when that is not the case,
because in fact, it often
is not the case.
So looking at the
family of things
that we might seek
to optimize, there
are really multiple things.
Right?
Some of which are easy to
make in a quantitative fashion
assessment of, models of,
and then optimize against
and some that are a little
bit more qualitative
or additional factors.
So certainly things like
quality is the main effect
that we've been looking at.
That is to say, we're
looking at the response
of one or more outputs as a
function of one or more control
factors or inputs
and then seeking
to optimize the overall yield,
overall output of the process.
You want to be on
target but you also
want to be as immune as
possible to variance.
And we talked earlier
in the term, not so much
last time on
Tuesday, but earlier
in the term about CPK and
quality loss functions.
But also, of course, another
key driver in all manufacturing
is cost, and there are
costs associated with yield,
of course.
You're only getting revenue
for things that are good.
But there's also other
cost factors, for example,
picking of different points
in the operating space
may imply different things about
cost of running of the process.
And in fact, one of the
important factors of cost
is associated with rate.
Very often your process
factors or what operating
point you pick for your process
has a direct parts per hour
or other kind of throughput
or rate implication, right?
In fact, you'll very
often have this trade off
where you might expect
if you run things faster,
your quality might be
a little bit reduced.
Whereas if you run
things at a reduced rate,
you may be able to boost
up yield or quality,
but there's a trade
off then in terms
of how much production
you can get out
or how rapidly you
can get that out.
In many of these cases,
if you can actually
fold all of those down into
a direct dollar trade off
then you can start to formulate
an overall cost function
or objective function,
sort of an overall J
function in our terminology from
last time, that might actually
trade off some of those things.
But often, it's
actually quite difficult
to get really
detailed information
and build models of
all of these factors.
Now an additional
factor is flexibility.
That's a little bit harder
to get quantitative about.
What do you think we
mean by flexibility?
I mean, we could find
the process optimum,
lock in our equipment, lock
down the control knobs,
and say that's where we're going
to operate for the next four
years.
That would probably
not be very flexible.
But give me some thoughts
on what kind of flexibility
you might want in a process?
AUDIENCE: Change over
time, like the process is
easy to modify and change.
DUANE BONING: Excellent.
Yeah, so the idea there
was change over time.
So a process.
So some of those might be
goals actually in the equipment
design or the line design.
Not necessarily picking
an operating point,
but definitely
flexibility is the ability
to rapidly do changeovers.
By the way, that
often folds into some
of these other factors, right?
Can affect cost, quality,
rate, change over time,
how rapidly you do that, can
have an impact on throughput.
Changeover sometimes
requires additional steps
to warm up or prove
in the new changeover.
So furthermore if your
equipment requires
a little bit of adjustment
after a changeover,
it can have a quality impact.
That's a good one.
I like that.
Other kinds of flexibility?
AUDIENCE: You could
[INAUDIBLE] and try
to make it more insensitive
to the exact operating point
to try to [INAUDIBLE]
development, rather,
something that gives
more room for the process
to [INAUDIBLE] on
either side [INAUDIBLE]..
DUANE BONING: Yeah, so
what Neil is just saying
is you might want to
process that is perhaps
less sensitive at an optimum.
So this would be less sensitive
so that as your inputs vary,
your outputs would vary less.
I think that's an
important characteristic.
That's a notion of robustness.
I'm not sure I would associate
that with flexibility, though.
I think it's a slightly
different idea.
I mean, certainly--
I'm trying to think how
to think of that as--
it may be that
what you would like
is a process where this
same characteristic might
be true of multiple
operating points
so that one could
rapidly, rapidly
tune in the process, rapidly
change over the process.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Different rates.
Output rates.
DUANE BONING:
Different output rates.
So what would the
benefit of that be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] demand.
We don't want to overproduce.
DUANE BONING: Interesting.
Sure.
So rate flexibility might
be another characteristic.
So I think we could identify
multiple of these flexibility
ideas.
I think these are really
important characteristics,
especially in overall
product design as well
as process design.
We haven't really talked
that much about it.
We're really focused
mostly, in this subject,
on the manufacturing process
control and the quality issues.
But I did want to have that
in there just as a reminder
that there's a lot of these
other kinds of factors
that are important in a
manufacturing setting.
But let's focus a
little bit, look
at minimizing,
well, quality loss
and thinking a little bit
more about other cost factors.
We've been saying that
one of the important goals
is we want the--
I'm not sure I would
use x bar here.
Let's call that y bar.
If y is my output, I
want my y bar output
to at least hit or come as close
as possible to some target.
So again, if we assume that
there is, in fact, some spread
in the manufacturing process,
I can never completely squeeze
out all the variance.
We have our typical
CPK-like picture
where we've got
some target, we've
got spec limits,
upper and lower,
and again, we want
to maximize yield.
So one important
characteristic of that
is getting on to target.
It turns out if you have
a fairly rich process--
rich in the sense that you've
got multiple inputs that you
can use to affect the process--
maybe you also have
multiple outputs.
But for the moment imagine that
I've got one output of concern,
but I've got more than one x
control factor or input factor.
Conceptually do
you think there's
going to be more than
one solution to or just
one solution to a combination
of those input factors
to hit the particular output?
If I only had one
input and one output,
seems like most
likely I'm only going
to have one setting
for that input that
is going to correspond to
a maximum on that output.
But if I've got multiple ones
and they have some influence,
you got an interesting
situation here, right?
You end up with multiple
solutions, if you will,
to the maximum output problem.
That is to say you
may have contours
in the multidimensional
space, an x1, x2, y space
that all achieve
the same output.
Turns out that's wonderful.
It means, well, yes,
you can match to target.
But now that second input
or the additional inputs
give you a little
bit of freedom to try
to achieve other goals as well.
Now that's assuming that
sort of the match to target
is the paramount
goal, and getting
close to that is pretty close
to a paramount goal because
of the direct effect on
yield and quality loss,
but it wouldn't
necessarily have to be so.
But here I'm sort
of assuming you've
got to get to target
first, and then
after that it's an opportunity
to choose your operating
point to do other things.
To do things like
minimize the cycle time
to get as fast a
rate as possible
or to start to fold
in other qualitative
or quantitative cost drivers.
A couple of simple
examples might
be at different operating
points you might actually
use more input materials
or, say, manufacturing
gases in a plasma reactor.
At different
operating points, you
might be more or less
efficient in the use of energy
or other material resources.
Another factor might be things
like at different operating
points, it has different side
effects on the equipment,
like wear of a machining tool.
OK?
So these are places where you
can start to add those in.
And that actually
means that you really
would like to have multivariable
models in the sense
of some output y that in
fact, does let you trade off
two or more inputs.
And this is just a
visualization of what
I was just describing earlier.
Here's a very
simple linear model,
two inputs with an interaction.
And now let's say that the
target value for y is 5.
Well, that plane intersects
with my response surface
along some line,
and you can sort of
see that dashed line there.
That indicates any combination
of the x1 and x2 factors
that can achieve that output.
And so now, in fact, to find
and decide what x1 and x2
I'm going to use,
I actually need
to think about some
other criteria.
Right?
I guess if it doesn't matter,
you can pick any of them
and you might randomly pick.
I guess randomly picking
is about the only thing you
can do where you're not,
I think, intuitively
applying some additional filter
or some additional criteria
to the x1 and x2.
So again, some of these might
be picking x1 and x2 based
on things like cost or rate.
What are some other
things that you
might use to decide on
which point along this space
you would actually like to
pick for an operating point?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Minimum variability.
DUANE BONING:
Minimum variability.
Good.
And we will talk
about that for sure.
Excellent.
AUDIENCE: If you were having
[INAUDIBLE] x1 but not x2,
then you will use x1 to control
most of the [INAUDIBLE]..
DUANE BONING: Interesting.
Yeah, so that's getting at
the notion of flexibility,
so the idea was if I had
some other product that
also was using x1
and x2, there might
be value in keeping one of
those variables constant
or using it to
optimize all of them
and then focusing in and letting
one variable be more associated
with the flexibility,
if you will,
the thing that you use to tune
in across different products
or different processes.
I like that.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Physical constraints.
Your machine might not
be able to go that fast.
DUANE BONING: Physical
constraints, absolutely.
So depends on whether these are
rate or other things in terms
of whether the machine
can go that fast,
but certainly you
may have explored
a space in these coded
variables in x1 and x2
that cover this broad range, but
perhaps your equipment really
doesn't want to run out here at
one of the extreme low points.
So that might actually drive you
away from these extreme points
or maybe it drives you towards
one of those extreme points.
In general, I think--
let's see, I believe
one of the case
studies-- it's either
case study two or three.
Dave Hardt will come in and
talk about run by run control,
a little bit of use of some
of these kinds of models
for feedback control.
And in general, an observation
that comes out of that is you
might want to avoid
operating at one
of the boundaries of
your process, right?
If you were, in fact, picking
one of these points that's
at the edge of the space that
you used to build your model,
well, you're not
really sure what
happens if you adjust x to a
little bit beyond that space.
You might hope that the process
continues to be well behaved
and extrapolate out
into that region.
That's a little
bit scarier to do.
But in general, if you
pick a point that's
closer to somewhere
in the interior,
almost maybe even the
center of your space,
that gives you the
maximum freedom
in an active control setting
to make small modifications
to your x1, x2 factors to drive
the process back onto target.
So I would be
inclined to also try
to sort of keep my
factors in a place
where I know I can keep moving
them to control the process.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE],,
doesn't it
make sense that if
possible you actually
need to test further
out because you could
have more optimal
conditions if you
could, say, push the boundary?
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
So the question-- yeah, yeah.
The question is kind
of a general one
about response surface
models and optimal points.
Is if you are on some boundary--
well, first off if I
have linear models,
very often you get
to the constraints
being a boundary especially
if I fold in something,
some additional factor.
And so you could always
ask the question,
should I extend my
experimental space
and explore a
little bit further?
And the answer is if
your variables naturally
can go beyond your initial guess
of the range of exploration,
absolutely.
And as we saw last
time, for example,
in incremental or
iterative optimization,
you may have actually already--
I guess I'm sort of
assuming you've already
explored the space to cover the
optimum region as much as you
can.
That's a good
observation as well.
Good.
Any others?
Any other ideas?
OK.
Good.
I did want to hit
on some of these.
Now we'll come back to
this minimum variance
because that is a
great idea, right?
So far here this picture
is still looking at, even
in this picture, it's still
looking at just output
and matching that
output to the target,
that shaded plane is
hitting the target.
And a bigger goal [INAUDIBLE],,
even just focused on quality
is overall yield and minimizing
either the effective variation
or minimizing the variation.
So if we go back to our
quality and variation equation,
my output can vary due to a
couple of different factors.
We said alpha are
sort of noise factors,
and these are the
actual process settings
if you will or control factors.
And so we can see
that they'll have
some sensitivity of
the process to each
of these kinds of factors.
If I tweak my x factor
or u factor a little bit,
my y is going to change some
amount and normally I can
control or I have power
over those process settings,
those options, but
sometimes I don't.
Sometimes I can dial it
in, but I don't always
get exactly what I dialed in.
So there might be differences
in sensitivity of the output
where little deviations
in x, especially
with a non-linear or
polynomial kind of model,
might actually imply
different amounts of delta y
at different operating points.
So that's an example where
our assumption about--
let me just get some
of you down here--
equal variance everywhere
in the process space
might actually not apply.
But also, we have
these noise factors.
We have these variation
sources, uncontrollable factors,
things that we can't
completely eliminate,
and we might want
to find an operating
point where we minimize the
sensitivity to those noise
factors.
OK?
So one way of thinking
about this as we
look back at just a
sensitivity kind of analysis,
where can I look at either
using my response surface
model, which usually
has this in it,
and minimize some
sensitivity metric on that
or start to try to deal a little
bit with these unmodeled noise
factors.
One approach here we're
going to talk about
is, what if I want to
include those in the model?
I actually want
to understand how
variance may change as a
function of operating point.
This is going to be a little
bit overcoming the assumptions
that we made.
Now how can I get
minimum variation?
I mean, so one approach
here is think about it
from the sensitivity
point of view.
The other is think about
it from a CPK perspective.
You know?
And we talked about needing
to center the process as one
part of that, but the other
part would be the variance part.
And again, here if I'm
doing anything other
than mean centering, I have to
know how the variance actually
depends on anything.
Our assumptions all along in
most of what we've done so far,
ANOVA and other kinds of
tools that we've looked at,
have sort of assumed that
the variance was constant.
We want to back off
and relax that as well.
And another perspective that
we'll look for a little bit
here is to look back at the
quality loss function, which
can fold in together.
Remember the quality
loss function
that says, as I deviate
my output from my target I
incur more and more loss?
It actually has a penalty,
not just it's good as long
as it's above the
lower spec limit
and below the upper spec
limit, but as I deviate
from the overall target I have
continuing incremental worse
behavior in the product.
So that's sort of a
generalization a little bit
of the focus away from just the
target to also the variance.
So what this is saying is
for many of these approaches,
whether you look at it from a
CPK or a quality loss function,
you need to know more
about the variance
or you need to know more about
the influence of the noise
factors in order to really
get to process robustness.
With what we've
done so far already,
you could do a little
bit of robustness
just with the response
surface models
just in terms of reaction
to modelled input,
but that's a pretty weak
notion of robustness.
That's only looking at
some of the variances.
Well, let's explore the CPK one.
This is actually
all just reminder.
We've said CPK is a nice measure
that looks at two effects,
right?
So the CP has an effect
from the deviation
from the mean of your process
where the true mean is
and how far away it is
from your spec limits,
so that's sort of a
centering or a target point,
and then it also has
a notion of folding
in the spread in
your process, right?
So one could, in fact, formulate
something like CP or CPK
as your cost function, your
penalty function, your J,
and try to build a model--
either use your model or
build a separate model--
and minimize some cost.
Well, in this case, maximize
the CPK because a bigger CPK,
we said, corresponds to yield.
In fact, we'd use
different formulas.
You could actually relate a CPK
to a fraction of nonconforming
parts given different values.
Another approach
would actually be
to extend that almost
directly and say,
what I'd like to do is
actually use J directly
or a model of CPK.
Build a response surface
model, if you will, of CPK,
and that would be a way to
fold in both mean information
and process variance
information.
What are some gotchas
in trying to do this?
What are some difficulties?
We said one of our purposes
here, it might be in fact,
pick your process operating
point to maximize CPK.
Why not just directly use that?
Use this function right here.
There's my function,
I want to maximize
K. Let me broaden the question.
What are some good things or
some bad things about this?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DUANE BONING: OK.
I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
is going to depend on y.
DUANE BONING: OK, so
the comment there--
by the way, you need
to try to speak loudly.
I'm trying to repeat the
questions or the answers
as much as I can, but I think
it's a little hard for people
to hear.
So I'm sorry, now I lost the
question-- or the answer.
AUDIENCE: One of
the things might
be that the sigma
might depend on mu
or [INAUDIBLE] may
depend on [INAUDIBLE]..
DUANE BONING: So one
of the complexities
you said is this might actually
be a function of the process
conditions.
Yes.
In fact I would even
almost say, this approach
here where I built a
quality overall CPK
and if I were able
to actually evaluate
CPK at each of my
process operating points,
that might actually be a way
to incorporate or accommodate
a change in variance or a
change in standard deviation.
Whereas in some sense, if
I build a response surface
model up front with the
assumption of a fixed variance,
it might then be hard to
actually use that fixed model
with just J as a cost function.
So these are two
slightly different ideas,
and I'm glad you
mentioned that because--
I mean, this idea,
the first idea
up here is basically saying,
I've already built my response
model, maybe for y.
I might, might, talk about
a response model for s,
and then I just use the
model or use CPK as my cost
that I'm minimizing.
The second idea, in
contrast down here,
is build a new response
variable and actually
build a model directly of
CPK as a function of my input
conditions.
And then I optimize on that.
They're slightly different
ideas because in that case,
in some sense this case
is, perhaps, assuming
we're mostly having a fixed s.
This one, as I said, can
perhaps more easily accommodate
a process varying
standard deviation.
There's one other
potential challenge
with the model down below.
Well, either approach, really,
with these two functions.
What's something that's a little
nasty about these functions?
They have things like
a min function in them.
A minimum.
And minimum between
two variables
can be very non-linear,
so it may not
be that smooth of a function.
There may be a point
at which you actually
start to break more to the
left side or to the right side
and have not a continuously
varying parameter.
So it can be a little
bit of a challenge
from a modeling point of view
as well as in optimization.
It's kind of a nasty function.
OK?
And in fact, that
nonlinear nasty behavior
with its possible
discontinuity is--
let's see, I want to--
ope, I guess I don't
have it in here.
It's kind of one of the main
drivers for the whole notion
of the quality loss
function, that E of L,
that quality loss function
with a quadratic dependence
on deviation from the mean is a
nice way of folding in together
in a more continuously
varying function,
both deviation from target
and effects of variance.
So we'll come back
to that, but in fact,
that's one of the main
reasons why the quality loss
function is used and
has an advantage is
it has a smoother behavior,
a behavior that drives
towards an optimum that
pulls in or folds in both
of those effects
and doesn't have
these discontinuities or not
quite as much of the nastiness
of these min functions.
OK?
OK, so I guess this
discussion and everything
we've been leading up to
is really starting to say,
OK, look.
In order to be able to fold
in both deviations from target
but also variation,
we need better ways
to model the variance.
In particular, the
variance that might not
be constant at your
entire process base
but may vary as a function or
depend on a operating point.
OK?
Now remember, in
some cases we've
been careful to remind
ourselves that there
were assumptions on constant
variance in our approaches.
But sometimes we haven't even
been explicitly mentioning
that, but I want to highlight
that some of the methods we've
been using and
developed actually
implicitly continued
that assumption
that sigma squared
or the variance
was constant
throughout the space.
So in ANOVA, the simple
ANOVA that we did, in order
to decide if an
effect is real we
were always comparing
a fixed offset
to natural variance
in the process
and we were always pulling
the estimate of variance
across all operating
points equally.
OK?
So we were enforcing
an assumption
that there was only one
natural underlying process
variance at work.
And then we were trying to say,
are there variances associated
with fixed offsets
that are larger
than the replicate noise?
So that was in there and we were
careful in talking about that.
But another place was actually
in regression model fitting.
When we formed a least
squares regression problem
and then solved it,
that actually equally
weights all of our data
and all of our deviations
from the model
prediction equally
and essentially, is also a
equal variance assumption.
Think of it this way.
If I had, in fact--
wait.
Let me draw it.
If I in fact had different
operating points or locations
where the variance
was very different
and I'm trying to fit a line
through this, but over here
I have a huge spread.
It may in fact be
the case that I
have less confidence
or a wider spread
here in picking a
point that corresponds
to where that line
is going to go
than in other regions
of this space.
Now they can still
appeal to best estimates,
but in terms of confidence in
the use of each of your data
points, there are alternative
regression approaches,
weighted regression approaches
that might say in regions where
I have less variance--
where I have more confidence,
I know those data points
are more solid--
I might actually give
them more influence
in the weighting in the
regression than other points
that I'm not so sure about.
And so weighted regression
approaches are available,
and probably the most
common weighted regression
is to apply a weight that's
inversely proportional
to the variance associated
with each of the operating
regions in your space.
OK?
So just wanted to
highlight that there are
approaches that go
beyond this assumption.
We've been assuming that
in both our regression
analysis and our ANOVA analysis
that we have one variant.
I think I alluded to a
book earlier this semester
called Analysis of Messy Data.
It's a wonderful book.
Or actually, there's
a series of books.
There's either two
or three of them.
But one of the
examples of messy data
is when the variance
is not constant
and there's one of the volumes
in that series is focused,
I believe, on
analysis of variance
when you don't have constant
variance throughout your space.
So there are places you can
look when things get messy.
OK.
OK, so what do we do?
We've been assuming
that but in reality,
I think we've made the point.
The process variation may
in fact vary or depend
on our operating point.
I've already talked
about the impact
in our variance equation.
If I had imperfect control
on a control factor,
I may have different
sensitivity--
that dy, du-- especially with
a non-linear model can vary.
But it's also just
simply the case
that the effect of
these noise factors
may be such that I
have different variants
at different operating points.
So what are some approaches?
All I've said so far is variance
may depend on your process
settings.
How are you going to study
that and understand it?
Well, let's do
design of experiments
but also include
an explicit model
for variance or
standard deviation.
So all we're doing here is
simply saying treat variants
as another process output.
And so it is possible to
include another response
variable, either s squared
or s or some variance model
and do our typical DOE
here on our input factors,
but now get enough data
that I can actually
build a model of variance at
each of my operating points.
Can I possibly do that
without replication?
No.
I have to have replicates
at each of my design points,
each of my DOE points.
I have to gather multiple
replicates in order
to have an estimate of the
noise at that replicate point.
So fundamentally,
you have to do more
than a non-replicated,
full factorial
DOE like we were
talking about that just
explores the operating space.
You've got to get more data
if you want a model variance.
You always have to
have much more data.
So you have to pick some
number of replicates
at each of your design points.
And now this goes
back to the tools
we talked about
earlier in the term
in terms of deciding what
sample size you need in order
to be able to have
different confidence
intervals on your estimate of
variance or standard deviation.
Right?
So depending on how
close, how accurate
you want to be on your
estimate of a variance, that
will influence how many
replicates you need.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: To get this at each
level, you do [INAUDIBLE]..
DUANE BONING: Right.
Right.
Absolutely.
So the comment or
question was, to do
this you actually
need replicates
at all of the points.
Yeah.
So in some sense, the DOE
that we were talking about,
this would be, say,
full factorial,
and then if I picked
my center point
we talked about doing something
where I had replicates only
at the center points.
And that's wonderful
if you're continuing
to assume that there's
only one variance
and it applies everywhere.
In fact, that's kind
of the assumption
we made, even
without necessarily
having good evidence for it.
But clearly here if I
want a model of both
the average output but the
variance at each point,
I mean replicates at each point.
And you would normally
want to do that where
you have the same number of
replicates at each point.
It's possible you could do it
without a balanced experiment
where you had different
numbers of replicates.
Then it gets really messy
because then your confidence
interval for your estimate of
variance at each of your points
is different.
You'd like to have at
least the same confidence
interval or the same
number of replicates.
Now there is some danger in
some of these kinds of models.
I wouldn't quite say
danger, I would say
some approximation going on.
So for example, one thing
that makes me a little bit
uncomfortable is actually
building a model directly
of standard deviation,
because estimating directly
standard deviation is
difficult. It's got bias in it.
Whereas building a model,
perhaps, for example,
of variance, you
can use the data
and get an unbiased
estimate of variance.
Whereas you're susceptible
to slight biases if you go in
and directly model
standard deviation.
But for the most part, people
pretty much ignore those.
And are basically--
I think assuming that
those kinds of biases
get washed out in
the noise because I
don't have so many replicates.
They tend not to be all
that careful with it,
but I would just put a
little side note here.
We should be a little bit
careful about the influence
of bias in these factors.
And in fact, I think in
one of the case studies
we'll talk about approaches
for modeling variance
and some of the biases
that can creep in.
But the main latch
here, the main lever
for being able to get some
power over the problem
is simply doing a DOE that
includes explicit modeling
of the variance so
that one can build up
some kind of a variance
or a standard deviation
response surface.
And then you can use
that in combination
with your output to form
a cost function that
seeks to minimize in some
way both of those factors.
So for example,
now we can go back.
We can go back to that
surface that we had.
That x1, x2 surface where
I found the line or some
function that minimized
the error in my output
from the target.
But then I can explore over that
within my x1 and x2 constrained
space and look for
the place where
I've got the minimum variance.
Right?
So if I took back--
if I go back here
to slide five--
I just heard a bell.
Is everything still
working there?
You still have the
slides in Singapore?
AUDIENCE: No, we don't
We don't have the slides,
it was just disconnected.
DUANE BONING: Yeah, I just--
AUDIENCE: You might want
to share the desktop again.
DUANE BONING: OK.
Yeah, it looked like
it dropped the call.
So while that's calling,
so the basic point was
if I have an additional
response surface
for variance or
standard deviation,
the simplest use
of that is simply
to still do my
optimization on the target
and then just look up or use
this to disambiguate my xy
parameters.
AUDIENCE: When you have
[INAUDIBLE] experiment
that we're doing, [INAUDIBLE]?
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
So the question was,
let's say you only did
four replicates at each point.
Well, you ask the
question, how good
is your estimate of
variance at that point?
And you know how to
calculate that, right?
And your point is with
only four replicates,
it's kind of iffy
about how good you're--
you're only going to
have resolving power
to be able to see really
big differences in variance.
If it's small
differences in variance
with that number of
replicates, you're
not going to really be
able to disambiguate.
So in essence with that small
number-- oh, thank you--
that small number of replicates,
you're really just looking
for gross variance differences.
Which if they exist, you
definitely want to use.
Now, if you're looking
for really trying
to get a good process that has
the ability to take advantage
of small variance
differences-- because
over many, many thousands
or millions of parts,
even small variances can
really make a difference.
Then you'd want to
run more replicates
in your design of experiments.
OK, are we back
at Singapore now?
You have the slides there?
AUDIENCE: No we don't.
AUDIENCE: They had it
and then they dropped it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we
can't see the slides.
DUANE BONING: OK.
So this one, it thinks
we're in a call.
Should I unshare?
What should I--
AUDIENCE: No, I think
it's coming back.
DUANE BONING: Oh,
it's coming back?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, yeah.
It's back.
DUANE BONING: OK, great.
Great.
Good.
Great, so here again, the
first and easiest idea
for combining models of both
mean with a y and variance
is use the variance
to simply pick
which of the x1, x2 combinations
such that you're on target,
give you minimum variance.
Now you can also
do that directly
and form an overall
optimization,
and this is just
working through that.
This is the direct
approach where
if I have a response
surface for my mean
and a response surface
for my variance,
I have a constraint
here first off
that I need an optimum
point that satisfies
my output hitting a target.
And then I can simply
solve together,
pick some x that satisfies
that, and plug that
into the s surface.
Continuing on, substitute
that in into the s surface
so that you basically
get some function
where I need to find the x sub
2 that minimizes my variance.
And then I can do a direct
analytic variance minimization
to solve for x2 and once I have
x2, I can solve back for x1.
So all I'm saying there is
you can just algebraically use
your two response surfaces.
If they are simple
and linear then
it's nice and easy to
drive that towards where
you have the best y
hat that's on target
that also is minimum variance.
Another approach, once
I have models for both--
again, if I have a model
for the mean response
and a model for variance--
is think about other
cost functions that
combine both of these effects.
So this is a bit more
general because it
allows us to look at, say,
the quality loss function
and have terms that penalize
us for deviation from--
I don't-- well, penalizes for
deviations from the target.
I'm just looking at this and
saying, I don't know why we--
let's just stick with
y here everywhere.
I don't know why
we switched to x.
So when I have deviations from
my optimum point from the mean,
that's going to
cost me something
and then I also have a term
associated with the variance.
And if both of those are
functions of my input
parameters, now I'm finding
again the best input parameter
that minimizes the
overall cost function.
Now there's a subtle
difference here between--
or more power between
one of these approaches.
This approach versus
the direct solution
approach in the previous slide.
The direct solution
on the previous slide
basically said, I have
two outputs and two inputs
and I'm trying to
pull those two things
into one overall optimum.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Professor?
DUANE BONING: Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: I think
we cannot see--
I think we can see a slide but
then we cannot see any drawing,
and actually we are now
stuck at slide five.
DUANE BONING: Oh, OK.
So that doesn't sound
like it's changing there.
AUDIENCE: We don't
really know which slide--
DUANE BONING: Yeah,
I'm on slide 14.
Yeah, I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: What we have
right now is slide 11.
DUANE BONING: Yeah,
so I'm not sure
if the sharing is working right.
Are there just long delays?
Should I unshare and reshare?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I would do that
first and then [INAUDIBLE]..
DUANE BONING: Oh, OK.
Well, let me reshare here.
Oh, we killed the coffee.
OK, do you guys see slide
14 there in Singapore yet?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we
can see it right now.
DUANE BONING: OK.
Great.
So let's see if this works.
We'll try continuing here.
The point I was going to make
is if I go back to slide 13--
see if you got 13 now.
Did 13 come up?
AUDIENCE: We can't
see on the screen,
but we can see behind
your projectors.
DUANE BONING: Oh, OK.
So that's what
we're using in the--
all right.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's all right.
DUANE BONING: OK, we'll
just use the projector then.
The point I was making
here on slide 12 and 13
is in some sense I've got
two outputs and two inputs.
I can directly solve the x1
and x2 to achieve both a y
on target and then a minimum s.
If I had three x's or four
input factors, this approach--
well, I might have
additional power
in terms of picking points.
But this approach actually can--
I guess it can work as well
if my variance actually
is different.
It has a unique minimum.
But the point I
wanted to make here
is that with minimizing of
the quality loss function,
it's a little bit more
natural in the output
and can combine
or led to explore
over a different mixture of
input factors a little bit more
naturally.
OK?
So it's a little bit more
general than assuming
immediately I've just
got an x1 and an x2
and I'm directly solving for
the outputs individually.
What it's letting me do is
essentially combine them
into a single cost
function, and it also
gives another little
bit of flexibility
that is an important
difference between this
and the previous approach.
In the previous
approach, we said
the constraint is your
output is exactly on target.
Is that true here?
No.
When we're minimizing this
combined penalty function
with two terms in it it's
actually a little bit more
flexible in another
important way, which
is to say it's allowing you
to maybe pick a point that's
off target slightly because
it's a lower variance
point and overall you'll win in
terms of yield or quality loss.
So it's a little bit
more flexible in letting
you make that trade
off between variance
and being exactly on target.
It doesn't presuppose
that your mean on target
is absolutely your best point.
So I like the quality loss
formalism a little bit
if, in fact, I have a
variance that also depends
on what operating point
I'm at, what x factors
and therefore also
what y point I'm at.
It lets me combine those
and trade those off
in a natural way.
Now by the way, the classic
quality loss function,
they also use a constant
factor between the variance
and being off target.
A generalization of
that is you can actually
use different weighting
factors in those two cases.
You may actually have, I don't
know, a customer that says,
I really want my mean to be--
maybe your customer
actually has some reason
to wait or be more
concerned about variance.
He likes a tighter
variance, but actually has--
as long as a mean is somewhere
in my spec region, I'm fine.
It's kind of an odd combination,
but there might be reasons
where you might weight
variance or being
near target a little
bit differently,
and so that's one nice
thing about this minimizing
of the expected loss.
You can actually weight those.
OK, so what are some challenges
here when the variance is
varying?
One challenge with minimizing
or variance [INAUDIBLE]
that we've already talked
about is you have to model it.
And what I want to
explore a little bit
are some of the
response surface model
or approaches for
actually building up
models of these dependencies.
Are you guys back?
I just heard another bell.
I'm just going to keep going.
AUDIENCE: No, we're
not but it's OK.
We can see the projector.
DUANE BONING: OK, we'll
continue with that.
I'll ignore the little bells and
the birds chirping and whatnot.
Now as we start to
look at ways to build
the model of the
process we can return
to the question
of what is it that
causes non-constant variance.
And part of the effect
is that our noise factors
may have different
influence at different parts
of the operating space.
So one approach for
building the model
and trying to get
places that are robust,
that is to say
insensitive to variation,
is actually explicitly play
with some of these noise
factors, additional
factors in our process
that we're not using directly
to control the process
and try to explore and model
what effect those noise factors
have directly on the process.
OK?
And so that gets
to, essentially,
an approach where we
can do an extension
to our design of experiments
where we explicitly
look not just at, say,
our main control factors.
So these might be our A
and B control factors.
But at each of our design
points, what we might do
is not just do pure
replicates but actually take
some of these other factors,
things we can kind of change
in the process but
in normal operation
we would not want to be.
Maybe it's a
machine setting that
has a big cost associated
with changing it
or a big time lag in it.
It's a noise factor
or some other factor.
What we might want to do
instead of just running
pure replicates is actually
look at these additional noise
factors and explicitly, in
the design of experiments,
tweak them, play
with them, bury them
in a small region around that
particular operating point.
And what that does is back
to our variation equation.
That's explicitly saying, I
know what my alpha factors are,
these noise factors, I'm
going to actually modify
them a little bit and
build a model that
gives me information about
sensitivity to those factors.
So this is referred to as
inner and outer factors.
What we've got if I do the same
thing at each of these corner
points, I've got
the inner design
and then I've also
got an outer design
where I play with these
additional factors
at each of the corners.
This, by the way, gets very
close to approaches often
referred to as
Taguchi approaches--
after one of the big spokesmen
for explicitly thinking about
dealing with noise and modeling
of noise and optimizing
processes to be
robust to noise--
where you've got this inner
and outer factor mixed design.
So let's see how this works.
Here's a very simple example.
We've got two main factors
in our inner array.
So if I do just a full
factorial in that,
we've got my four combinations.
Right?
And then here, instead of
running pure replicates,
what we're doing
is an outer array
where we vary the levels in
another little full factorial
around each of
those corner points.
And so now you can imagine
that that's giving us
an ability to model the
mean response, again,
at that corner point, but
also a notion of variance.
If I just treat those
as pure replicates
and build a model or an
estimate of variance,
that gives me kind of a
funny, slightly different way
of thinking about the variant.
It's actually a
perturbed variant,
but I'm thinking of that
as in my normal operation
those might be noise factors
that I'm not explicitly
controlling and might
randomly be picked
at one of those
settings and so I'm
going to treat them, for
the purpose of my process
optimization, for the purpose
of robustness, as overall noise.
Right?
So in essence, it's lumping
together these other factors
in order to explicitly
and proactively explore
the space in those factors and
get an estimate of variance
at each of our operating points,
at each of our corner points.
OK?
So then you can build a model.
You could build a model
both of the average output
and of the variance.
Another part of the
methodology popularized
by Taguchi is to say, I
don't want two outputs
that I have to somehow
then optimize separately.
I want to fold these things in
together into one combined cost
function that I then optimize.
And the particular cost function
that he refers to or uses
is a signal to noise ratio,
where what you're trying to do
is get on target or
maximize some output,
but also then minimize variance.
And he actually has
multiple different factors,
but one can imagine building
a signal to noise ratio
that looks at the ratio
of output mean to variant.
You take the log so that it
becomes more of a linear model
and form a signal to noise.
And so here, for
example in the picture,
is an example of an overall
integrated cost function,
a signal to noise ratio
function where you might want
the maximum signal to noise--
larger output, smaller
variance-- and this
would drive you towards an
optimum point in your space
based on where you're going to
achieve that notion of best.
OK?
So there's a couple of
ideas on this slide.
One here is simply
this notion of how
you do the design with
the inner and outer array
and then the other is this idea
of a natural way of combining
both variants and target
different than the expected
loss function, but
kind of related to it
are the signal to noise ratios.
And if you look
in the literature,
there's different ones depending
on what kind of objectives
you have qualitatively.
For example, if you really
want to be close to the nominal
and be insensitive
to the noise, then
that cost function that we just
described on the previous slide
is a pretty good one.
There's other places where
maybe your main driver is really
trying to get as--
do I have this right?
I may have this--
no, I think I have this right
because of the negative there.
You might have a slightly
different signal to noise ratio
if you're more
driven towards you
want a large output, a
large y, or another one
if you want a small y,
you want to minimize y.
So you can still formulate these
things in slightly different
signal to noise metrics.
So let's explore this inner
and outer array design
approach a little bit more.
This is often referred to
as a crossed ray method.
One question that
comes up is, gee,
looks like an awful
lot of experiments.
So we do want to understand
how many experiments there are.
Are there ways to minimize
that or reduce that?
And overall, it's
clear that I've
got something that requires
both control factor
tests in the inner array,
but also noise factor
tests associated with
additional variations
right around each of the points.
OK?
And it can actually
be even worse
than just sort of
what I've drawn here,
because if our goal is really
to get to an optimum point that
hits the target and really is
an optimum point in a target,
you may even need something
more than just a full factorial
on your x1 and x2 parameters.
Think back to what we
talked about on Tuesday.
We said if you're
trying to drive
the process to an
optimum y, you might
have locally linear models.
But if you really
have an optimum y--
not just at some target,
but some overall optimum--
what you need to get to is
some natural maximum or minimum
point, which is a place
where you've got something
like, say, quadratic curvature.
So ultimately your model
for y, if you really
are trying to get
to a true optimum it
may require some notion of
a quadratic model, at least
in terms of your output as
a function of your input.
So one approach was
it might actually
require, for example,
a three level model.
And in that case, things
get bad really fast, right?
If I really needed a
true three level model
on each of my x1, x2 inputs,
now I go as 3 to the K sub C
where K sub C is the
number of control factors,
K sub N is the number
of noise factors.
So that could grow
really, really fast.
Fortunately we know
I don't necessarily
have to do a full
three level factorial.
There are other approaches
like central composite
that can build me a
quadratic model in the output
without needing so
much replication.
I don't have to have
necessarily full three
levels on all of my factors
because I don't really have
that much interaction going on.
But the point here
is if I'm really
trying to explore the
space for building up
my estimate of my
output, I might well
need a quadratic model in that.
Do you think it gets that
bad for the noise factors?
Do I need a quadratic kind of
model for my noise factors?
In other words, why not?
If I look at this
little corner point,
why don't I need a quadratic?
Should I include a
center point there?
Should I include multiple
exploration around that
as well?
Do I need a quadratic model
of variance at each corner?
What are we using
this exploration
in this corner array to do?
We're just using it to
exercise these noise factors
and build up an aggregate
into one estimate of variance
at that point.
We are rarely actually trying to
build a local quadratic model.
I'm just using it--
think of it almost as structured
replicates at the corner.
I don't really need
that kind of resolution.
So you typically
will not see things
like doing a central composite
design at each corner,
something like that.
Something very simple
like a factorial,
either full or even
fractional factorial.
This is a beautiful place
for fractional factorial
in those corner points.
If I had eight noise
factors, I do not really
need to do the
eighth exploration
at each of my corner points
because I don't really
care if it's a third or
fourth or sixth order
interaction between
noise factors, what
I would like to do--
I don't care about confounding.
Confounding is
great, no problem.
I want to lump them all
together and just get
one estimate, in fact, of
overall noise variance there.
So very reduced models--
whoops.
I didn't want to do that.
Very reduced models.
Heavily fractional factorial
in those corner points
are very effective
for this purpose.
Another approach
that we can use here
is we could actually go beyond
that notion of just lumping
it all together just trying to
get an estimate for variance
at that point and actually
treat my control factors
and my noise factors
almost on equal basis.
So the purposes of our
design, why distinguish them?
I might actually want
a functional dependence
on the noise factor,
maybe because that
allows me to sort
of more naturally
fold it all in together
into one big experiment.
So in that case, you
can easily imagine
building a single
integrated model that
has linear
interaction, maybe even
quadratic dependencies
on my control factors.
But also that has
terms in it that
look like essentially
different parts of the problem
that we might be interested in.
One of those would
be terms like this.
I've got a gamma times z1.
Well, what's that doing?
That's telling me
essentially the sensitivity.
That's Dy to Dz1.
That's one of these
alpha noise factors.
I directly have a measure
there of sensitivity
to noise, that noise
factor at that point.
So that might be a
very useful thing
to know and actually
model and distinguish.
A second one are terms
that look like this.
Here's an x1 and z1.
What's this telling me?
Well, this is telling me
there's an interaction
between my x variable
and that noise factor.
So I know, depending on
where I pick my x variable,
I've got a different sensitivity
to noise at that point.
So that's kind of breaking that
part of the overall response
out and letting you
explicitly say, yes, now I
understand that interaction.
I understand how
my noise interacts
with that particular
factor and I
can use that to help
guide my optimization
and selection of input points.
So there is some value
in going ahead and doing
an integrated effect and
noise response surface
approach where you can build
up an integrated model together
in here.
And then you can use
the same techniques
that we talked about last time,
about aliasing and worrying
about which interaction
factors and how high your order
interaction really
needs so you can
go ahead and get reduced
models and fold some of those
together.
But it essentially allows
us to explicitly think
about both control
factor responses,
but interaction with
the noise factor.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do we have a
control on triggering
the level of noise?
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
So the big assumption
in here is, in fact,
many of these noise factors
in the design of experiments,
while you're doing your
upfront process optimization,
that you actually can vary them.
AUDIENCE: That's a noise.
[INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Yeah, it's
kind of a funny term.
Yeah, I'm glad you
raised that question.
The question is we've got these
noise factors and the term
calling the noise factors--
one strong
interpretation of noise
is it's something I
have no control over.
This is a weaker notion.
This is basically
saying there are
things like in the normal
operation of the equipment
I can't vary them or
in the normal operation
they will be
naturally varied over
and I can't set and specify and
keep it at that noise factor
at one of these.
So here's what I'm
thinking as a good example.
Temperature, room
temperature, say.
So you know in normal
operation throughout the day,
the temperature from the
morning to the afternoon
might be varying in your factory
and you've only got a limit.
You can't really
completely control that.
Maybe you're operating in a
place where it has a big range
and you don't have
any control over it.
So what you would want to do
is understand that while you're
doing your process design.
Treat it as a noise
factor, know it's impact,
but then in actual operation,
I can't pick my temperature.
It's going to just
vary, but you would
like your process to be
as robust as possible
to that factor.
So that's the kind
of noise factor
here is things that
you can either actively
control during the
design of experiments
or naturally sample from during
the design of experiments.
Other things would be operator.
So that's a very good question.
I'm glad you asked that.
OK.
Once you've got a noise
response kind of surface,
now what you can also
do is build outputs.
Not only as a function of--
mean responses as a
function of your input
where you would essentially
ignore the noise factors,
but also if you just
simply take the variance
of this relationship
that gives you
a model for the variance
of the response when
under the assumption
that x are constant.
So in other words, what we do
is we can build two of these,
one under the assumption
such that my noise factors
are at the mean.
So I'm basically just
lumping all of those
into some overall noise
from my noise factors.
And then in my
variance case, I just
look at the terms that relate
to the interactions assuming
some x is relatively constant.
So we ignore these terms
or lump all these terms
into just the overall
gamma and then include
some of the interaction
terms with my z.
So essentially what
this lets us do
if we built an overall
response surface is
separate out and explore both
the mean response and also
variance as we try to pick
an x1 and our x2 to minimize
the sensitivity to
those noise factors.
Yes, there was a question?
Singapore?
AUDIENCE: Prof, do
we need to check
the r squared before calculating
the mean and then the variance.
Whatever the r squared
is, it's not very good.
It's [? small. ?]
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
Yeah.
So this sort of
goes without saying.
I was just assuming that you
use all of the normal response
surface modeling methodology.
You have to check significance
of each of these terms.
You would only include terms
if they are significant.
So it's more than just
checking r squared,
you really are running ANOVA.
Does that noise factor
have an effect or not?
If not, you just lump it
into an overall aspect.
So all of the typical
model construction
you would still want to do.
So anyway, the point here
is now if you explicitly
do a response surface
model, now you can
build models of the variance.
This is just an
explosion or expansion
of the variance
surface in general
you will observe
because of this squaring
in the variance expression.
It typically is quadratic in
your x1 and x2, which is nice
because then if you're trying to
minimize that variance if it's
quadratic in x1 and x2,
it does tend to drive
towards a nice minimum point.
I have one quick example
and then we'll be done.
This is alluding back
to our robust bending
where I've got a
punch and I'm trying
to get a bend in a
piece of sheet metal,
and we might have a
couple of control factors
that again, we can use
to optimize the process.
Like how deep I push
the punch and what
the width of the width
of the initial punch dye
is, but here's an example
of a couple additional noise
factors.
It may be we know that some
of the incoming material
will have a range of yield
points and thicknesses.
Again, I'm not going to be able
to necessarily select those.
I want to process it, it's
going to be robust to those.
But in a design
of experiments, I
can certainly sample from
different incoming material
types that explore that.
So I could then do a
design of experiments
where I vary both yield point
and thickness of the input.
I can build up a model
of z, I can build up
a model of the angle, I
can go in and do estimation
of both my main effect
on my control factors,
on interaction terms.
I could then estimate the
size of those coefficients,
go in and make sure that
they are significant,
and overall get down
to say something
that looks like a reduced
model where I might
be looking and saying, aw, OK.
That little beta 1,
2, 3 is insignificant.
I'm not going to include an
x1, x2, x3 factor, for example,
in the model.
Here's the example of
the reduced order model.
In this case, the mean
surface is nice and linear
with an the interaction term.
So we could go and do
optimization purely
on the mean surface trying
to hit some target angle,
but I can also look at
the variant surface.
And in this case, the
variant surface has--
it is a quadratic, it's
just a weakly quadratic.
But you can see a very,
very strong dependence
in the variance
on this x2 factor.
I think that was the
thickness factor.
Very big differences
in variance.
And so then I could combine
those two in different ways
to form an optimization
and try to get
to a good robust
operating point and that
might be a Taguchi
signal to noise
or it might be an
expected loss function.
In this case here,
I've plotted out
what the expected loss surface
is as a function of x1 and x2,
and if you're seeking to
minimize that you can start
to see a region there where
you would want to be in terms
of the x1, x2 to have a
good on target or close
to target and a low
variance process.
OK.
I'm going to skip
over this slide.
It's basically just
talking about a summary
of doing the combined
response surface
model with a little bit
of an assessment of maybe
the number of
different design points
that might be required
in those cases.
But what I wanted to do here
is just conclude and give you
the high level perspective here
is we did lots of machinery
on response surface
modeling talking mostly
about mean output, but that
same machinery can also
be used with some extra ideas
of these inner and outer arrays
for also modeling
variance when it
varies as a function
of operating point.
And then we can
combine those together
to try to get processes
that are robust to not only
selection of operating point,
but also to these kinds
of noise factors.
So with that, I'll conclude and
we'll see you all on Tuesday.
I think on Tuesday we'll
talk about nested variances,
so it's going to be a
little bit different.
We're going to pull back from
the design of experiments
and talk a little bit more about
interesting variance structures
often arising in places like
semiconductor manufacturing
and elsewhere.
So we'll see you on Tuesday.